once I remove the battery I can safely
disconnect the cables and we can get
started on the battery replacement every
iPhone battery is going to expire that
is it's going to go bad over time for
some pretty technical reasons so a few
months ago I shared that my iPhone 14
PR's battery had depleted faster than my
previous iPhones Joanna Stern actually
um mentioned that hers is down to 88%
capacity the Wall Street journalist
Joanna Stern said her iPhone 14 pro is
down to 88% and I shared some hidden
numbers about its battery health as of
today as the battery hits 494 charge
cycles the battery health is at
87% but what the heck do those numbers
mean where can you find them and why did
this battery deplete so fast in just a
year I found the answers to all of that
and
more there's no such thing as a lithium
ion battery that lasts forever so Apple
lets you know just how healthy your
battery is in the software go to
settings battery battery health and
charging see that maximum capacity
that's a measure of the battery capacity
relative to when it was new when I first
unboxed this iPhone 14 pro it was at
100% now a year later it's at
87% yes as that number gets lower the
battery doesn't hold to charge as long
think of it like a shrinking gas tank
and it's when that number gets into the
low 80% range that you start to worry
according to Apple's website a normal
battery is designed to retain up to 80%
of its original capacity at 500 complete
charge cycles when operating under
normal conditions but what's a charge
cycle Safety First obviously I got a
bicycle to explain Cycles there we go
all right 500 Cycles one two how's this
working okay let's pretend this week
wheel is your battery you complete one
charge cycle when the battery goes from
100% to
0% it's basically like the tour def
France but you don't complete a cycle
every time you charge say you use 80% of
your battery one day and then recharge
it to 100% overnight if you use 20% the
next day you will have discharged a
total of 100% so yes it could take
multiple days to complete one cycle that
lithium ion battery in your phone is
rated for 500 of these Cycles anyone
have a snack nearing 400 Cycles thank
you this is how they do it 450 and as
you get closer to 500 Cycles the more
that battery capacity percentage is
going to go down and yes the battery
will drain faster when you use it and
500 why is it getting so
slow why is it so hard to
pedal how do you find out the number of
charge cycles on your phone well the new
iPhone 15 models actually show it go to
settings General about then scroll down
to cycle count for other iPhones you can
download this software called coconut
battery to your Mac when you plug in
your phone it will show the cycle count
which brings me back to my iPhone 14 pro
I had hit 494 charge cycles in a year
which makes me seem like a total phone
add
which obviously I am not but I don't
think I use the phone that much more
than my iPhone 12 Pro which after 2
years of use had 652 charging cycles and
88% battery health but I had two leading
theories about why the 14 expired
quicker number one software some app or
some part of iOS was causing the battery
to drain faster thus I was charging it
more so more cycle counts happened it's
going to hurt tomorrow number number two
heat I did a previous video on this but
heat is the number one enemy of
batteries oh no it is it is so maybe
something inside my phone was getting
warm or causing the battery to fail
quicker when I took it to an Apple store
I was told there was no Hardware issue
an apple spokesman pointed me to the
company's website and said that given
the Cycles my battery's performance was
in line with what's promised okay so
this battery expired quicker but it will
happen to all iPhone batteries EV
which brings us to two choices buy a new
iPhone or replace your battery which is
going to be a lot cheaper and better for
the environment so I went to a local New
York City repair shop to explore the
replacement options how many battery
Replacements would you say you do
battery Replacements are actually one of
our most common repairs uh especially on
Apple devices I would say we get a few
devices every day even though it's a
common misconception that the battery
can't be replaced cuz you know back in
the day we used to just pop the back
open replace a battery with something we
found online and that was it the
batteries are actually very easily
replacable usually takes about 15 to 20
minutes but not all battery Replacements
are equal Joe here offers two options so
the battery we have here on the left
would be the Apple original versus an
aftermarket battery which we purchased
from uh suppliers that produce them for
shops like us those aftermarket or
thirdparty batteries tend to work as
well according to Joe but you will get
the following message on the phone that
basically tells you that it's unable to
determine if your iPhone battery is a
genuine Apple part and it tells you to
go to settings to get more information
about it you can dismiss that initial
popup but it will still show in settings
plus you won't be able to see all that
battery health information an apple
spokesman pointed me to a report citing
a study by the UL saying that in tests
third-party batteries overwhelmingly
failed to meet safety standards Joe says
he buy safe highquality batteries the
easiest way to avoid the error message
is to get your battery swapped at an
Apple store or an apple authorized
repair shop and honestly it might cost
about the same to do it there too Joe
said it would cost $89 for the iPhone 14
Pro battery replacement at his store the
Apple Store quotes
$99 why should I opt to come here the
Apple's warranty is a 90-day warranty on
the on the batteries we offer a
six-month warranty we also are able to
replace the battery within 10 to 20
minutes versus Apple's lengthy process
sometimes can take an hour sometimes 2
or three depending on how busy they are
so what did we learn here today well if
you don't want your battery to go bad
don't charge your phone seriously though
you can keep those charge cycles down by
reducing use relying on low power mode
will help too there's also a new setting
on the iPhone 15 that will stop charging
at 80% to preserve health and definitely
keep your phone out of the heat but you
can't live your life babying your
battery it's like I guess we'll just be
sitting here preserve and charge
cycles
great